[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans 78 actu nous
allons passer en revue l'actualité
locale du jour et nous débutons avec
cette unité de prévention qui est venu
faire une sensibilisation ce mardi matin
au lycée Matis de trappe une unité
unique en France l'upsr c'est son nom
l'unité de prévention des conduites à
risque un camion qui circule sur tout le
territoire national et pendant un mois
il sillol NES iines et s'est arrêté
pendant 2 jours attrape l'objectif
parler donc des conduites à risque par
exemple ce mardi matin au lycée Matis le
chef d'établissement a demandé que ses
élèves soient sensibilisés sur les
nouvelles technologie les violences
physiques verbales et sexuelles à
travers Internet il y a aussi tout un
travail fait autour de l'usage des
drogues et toutes sortes de dépendance
alors ici pas vraiment de diffusion de
film pas de grand discours mais plutôt
un échange avec les élèves les
jeunes parlent librement le souci qu'ils
ont c'est que ils ne font pas eux-mêmes
les recherches donc ils sont beaucoup
sur les idées reçues on m'a dit que donc
du fait que on m'a dit que c'est bien
donc je serais peut-être poussé à
essayer à expérimenter le le produit et
malheureusement derrière c'est ce qu'on
explique nous si jamais tu viens
expérimenter un produit et que tout de
suite tu adhères euh tu risques
malheureusement de tomber dans la
dépendance et qui dit dépendance hein
dit euh ben qu'au niveau de ta liberté
déjà il y en a plus beaucoup euh tu
feras tout pour retourner vers le
produit et donc ça peut passer déjà dans
un premier temps par le raquette dans
les établissements scolaires euh ça peut
passer par les vols directement auprès
des parents hein euh dans les les
portefeuilles les pores-monnaaies et euh
par la suite euh le deal et et cetera et
cetera al un tout autre sujet du
cyclisme pour continuer ce mardi matin
Christian prudom directeur du Tour de
France et le président du conseil
général Alain schmidz ont dévoilés le
parcours de l'édition 2014 du Parini
c'est la 72e édition et pour la 2e année
consécutive la course du soleil s
lancera des Yvelines alors cette fois-ci
le pleuton vous l'avez vu partira de
mant-elajolie pour première étape de 162
km avant de retrouver la ville de
Rambouillet pour la deuxè étape mais les
coureurs malheureusement ne passeront
pas par 50 ans ni ni le vélodrome
national alors spécificité cette année
de la course du soleil il n'y aura pas
de contre la montre h étapes en ligne où
le titre devrait se jouer sur les tous
derniers kilomètres à proximité de Nice
départ donc prévu le 9 mars et nous
reviendrons en détail dans notre édition
de demain sur cet événement qui marque
le début de la saison de vélo allez
social maintenant le quartier du valibou
en panne la deuxième tranche de travaux
de réhabilitation qui devait démarrer en
novembre 2012 n'a toujours pas débuté un
comble pour les locataires qui clament
leurs exaspération et l'office HLM
évoque des règlementation contraignante
450 logements sont en attente donc de
rénovation Olivier Maniscalco fait le
point regardez-moi ça depuis 20 ans
vraiment on vit dans la misère c'est
incroyable regardez-moi ça à plaisir les
habitants du quartier valibou en ont
assez prévu au départ en novembre 2012
la deuxème tranche des travaux de
rénovation la résidence HLM n'a toujours
pas débuté et pour les locataires la
situation est devenue indécente il y a
des rat il y a du cafar il y a de la
miante vraiment nous voulons un
organisme départemental qui vient pour
voir quand même c'est des êtres humains
qui vivent dans un quartier aujourd'hui
les habitants demandent clairement des
comptes au bailleur social la société
opivois un bailleur qui justifie son
retard par une nouvelle législation sur
le désamage des bâtiments avant tout
travaux afin de protéger les
travailleurs qui effectueront cette
rénovation cette nouvelle législation
nous a contraint à passer des marchés
publics puisque nous sommes un office
qui travaille avec uniquement des
marchés publics marchés publics c'est
plutôt long à monter et donc tous ces
éléments
supplémentaires nous ont fait prendre du
retard dans cette réhabilitation si au
Pivois se déclare de bonne fois certains
jugent le délai des diagnostics sur la
miante beaucoup trop long du côté de la
municipalité on souhaite clairement
accélérer les démarches j'ai lancé des
démarches déjà l'opivois a reçu une
grande diatrip de ma part assez
virulente aujourd'hui j'ai j'ai vraiment
envie que l'opivois nous regarde et nous
respecte et respecte les habitants
selonivois la tranche de des travaux et
ses 450 logements à rénover ont 90 % de
Chan de commencer fin 2014 il devrait
durer 2 ans allez on continue ce journal
avec l'entretien du soir on va parler du
Trophée d'improvisation culture et
diversité avec nos invités trophée qui a
été créé en 2010 à l'initiative de
Déclic Théâtre et de la Fondation
Culture et diversité cette année il y a
près
2606 élèves et 12 collèges des villes de
Bordeaux Lille Paris Rochefort ou encore
trappe qui s'entraîne toute l'année pour
participer à cette grande finale qui
aura lieu le 19 mai à Paris et en
attendant il y a deux collèges en tout
cas de trappe qui vont défendre les
couleurs de leur ville c'est le collège
Courbet et le collège Gagarine et donc
en attendant cette grande finale du 19
mai il y a un match intercollège qui a
lieu vendredi soir nourakin bonsoir
bonsoir alors un petit mot sur ce match
intercollège qui a lieu vendredi soir à
trappe alors un petit mot voilà c'est un
match qui un grand mot aussi un grand
mot ouais bon si je la fais longue en
tout cas voilà c'est un match en tout
cas qui va qui va permettre aux élèves
des deux collèges qui ne se connaissent
pas a priori
euh de se rencontrer de de se mélanger
parce que c'est pas un collège contre
l'autre ils vont ils vont jouer dans
dans des équipes complètement mixtes
donc c'est complètement amical et puis
c'est dans l'objectif de voilà de de de
d'affiner un petit peu quelle équipe de
de six élèves ira représenter la ville
de trappe dans ce championnat
intercollège et alors on a deux
représentants dignes représentants de
ces collèges leilla et Lucas en plateau
je vais vous poser quelques instants
quelques questions dans quelques dans
quelques instants mais pourquoi les
collèges Courbet et Gagarine ils sont
leaders en matière d'impôt sur
l'agglomération euh non non non pas du
tout sur l'agglomération on a on a 10
collèges qui sont assidus au au au
smitth au championnat intercollège mais
il y a pourquoi courb Gagarine c'est
parce que l'initiative de de de ce
trophée culture et diversité c'est c'est
Jamel de Bou voilà qui est revenu nous
voir en en voulant voilà un petit peu
profiter de notre expérience et faire
valoir notre expérience en fait de de de
15 années de développement du du
championnat intercollège sur
Saint-Quentin à une échelle plus
nationale et donc là on on il s'est dit
bon benah on va intégrer le collège je
courvé parce que c'est mon ancien
collège et Gagarine parce qu' j étais
surveillant toutement et tout simplement
mais l'idée reste quand même voilà
d'être dans dans dans un développement
cette année on accueil Paris et puis
voilà à partir de l'année prochaine on
espère encore pouvoir inéer grandit
d'année en année c'est la 4e édition les
deux premières éditions ont été
remportées par trappe la 3è édition par
Rochefort alors qui gagnera la 4e
peut-être ce sera peut-être ce sera vous
lea et Luca alors expliquez-moi déjà
tous les deux pourquoi vous avez choisi
de faire du du théâtre d'impro laa ça
fait 3 ans tu en fait et en plus toi tu
as eu la chance de participer au Trophée
de l'année dernière alors explique-moi
pourquoi tu as choisi le théâtre d'impo
bah pour commencé j'ai vu un match dans
mon collège et j'ai trouvé ça marrant
intéressant j'ai voulu m'inscrire pour
voir ce que ça donnait et quand j'ai
j'ai commencé tout de suite j'ai aimé
j'aimais bien ça m'aidé à me défouler à
rencontrer de nouvelles personnes puis
j'ai continué après on m'a annoncé que
en deè année que je feraiis la finale de
France et voilà j'étais contente et j'ai
rencontré CR de nouvelles personnes et
tu dis ça ça me ça me permet de me
défouler parce que c'est c'est vraiment
physique le T d' notre énergie tout ce
qu'on a en nous on le sort et et quand
j'ai commencé à l'Impr je le faisais le
vendredi alors tout ce que j'ai accumé
dans la semaine je le sortais du coup tu
parlais fort tu
gesticulais fait pourquoi tu as pas
choisi par exemple le théâtre tout
simple plutôt que le théâtre d' bien
parce que moi ce que j'aime c'est
improvisé c'est le théâtre et le TH
d'impro enfin il y a une différence
c'est plus intéressant l'impro
intéressant Luc alors toi tu en fais
depuis 2 ans alors explique-moi pareil
pourquoi tu as choisi le théâtre d'impo
et ah moi j'ai choisi le théâtre d'impo
parce qu'en fait au début je cherchais
une classe sport mais comme il y en
avait plus dans mon collège et euh vu
que ma sœur m'avait dit que c'était vu
qu'elle l'avait fait elle m'avait dit
que c'était bien ben je l'ai fait VO
après j'ai je l'ai fait la première fois
ça m'a plu j'ai continué j'ai continué
et j'ai joué plusieurs matchs donc voilà
et qu'est-ce qui te plaît dans le C
d'impro bah c'est d'improviser ouais
mais est-ce que ça s'apprend nurel Yakin
à improviser parce que euh est-ce qu'on
peut rappeler un petit peu les règles en
fait il y a il y a il y a des situations
ils doivent improviser à partir de
situations euh qu'il connaissent
pasavanceal à part entière en fait hein
c'est ça qui c'est la Comédia de l'art à
ses codes Mia ou Shakespeare en nom
d'autres et et voilà match
d'improvisation aussi moderne que cela
puisse être ça a aussi un certain nombre
de codes et puis surtout ça a des
techniques de de travail donc ce qu'on
leur apprend à laa Lucas et aux autres
dans dans leurs établissements c'est
c'est bah voilà c'est utiliser c'est
utiliser tout ce qu'on a en nous en
étant un peu matière première de de ce
qu'on peut produire en en spectacle et
pour pour développer des histoires et du
coup on on leur donne des billes voilà
des des règles apprendre à dire oui
apprendre à analyser ce qui est une
proposition quel est l'axe de l'histoire
l'objectif de notre histoire pour qu'ils
puissent eux-mêmes développer des
histoire en groupe voilà mais c'est un
vrai travail d'écoute c'est une vraie
discipline c'est pas la même posture que
quand on a le texte qui est inscrit sur
une feuille c'est une autre posture mais
c'est une posture théâtrale qui qui qui
qui qui est tout aussi riche et ce
trophée national d'improvisation culture
et unersité c'est un peu la serce sur le
gâteau pour des élèves comme ça qui ont
bah voilà qui jouent dans des matchs
entre au sein de leur collège ou entre
entre collège de l'agglomération c'est
la laerie sur le gâteau ouais nous on
est on est très fier de ça parce que
on on vous voyez bien qu'à l'échelle de
550 an en Yveline
déjà la rencontre des élèves voilà quel
que soit leur milieu et on sait que que
notre territoire est riche effectivement
de de de de de différents profils
sociaux mais cette rencontre là sur une
scène de théâtre où où on part tous sur
la la même ligne de départ pour
développer des histoires il y a pas de
on n'est pas confronté à la lecture par
exemple et et se mettre en difficulté
c'estàdire qu'on peut faire du théâtre
sans savoir lire avec le match
d'improvisation et puis aller vers vers
la province c'est aussi pour nous et
accueillir la province ici à Paris ça se
passe à Paris la finale on verra comment
ça se passera dans le développement mais
accueillir la accueillir les les les les
gens ici on a beaucoup de provinciaux
qui ne sont jamais montés à la capitale
qui ont leur âge qui découvre Paris et
qui découvre desah des des des donc
c'est un échange enrichissant ben oui et
puis d'autant plus que rochfort voilà
qui un milieu social voilà très
particulier et puis je parle d'eux parce
que je su je je suis très fier de ce qu'
représente aussi dans notre championnat
et et avoir rochfort qui remporte le
championnat l'année dernière ça ça a
beaucoup de valeur dans dans le dans
dans dans ce qu'on défend nous dans la
mesure où où effectivement on on connaît
Bordeaux on connaitt Lille on connaît
trappe peut-être plus que Rochefort
aujourd'hui et ça c'est rigolo tout à
fait bah merci en tout cas à vous trois
d'être venu sur le plateau donc je
rappelle hein cette finale du trophée
d'improvisation culture et diversité
c'est le 19 mai au théâtre la comédie à
Paris mais en attendant si vous voulez
voir des matchs impr de qualité et ben
rendez-vous donc ce vendredi soir à
l'école de musique et de danse de Trapp
pour voir le match intercollège entre
Gagarine et Courbet et des meilleurs
sortiront l'équipe qui ira donc en
finale le 19 mai à Paris merci à vous
trois d'être venu en plateau allez on
poursuit cette édition avec le troc en
force à Plaisir près de 2000 CD DVD
livres ont été proposé au troc un mode
de consommation qui revient au goût du
jour Yolan Torz et Patrick jacqu de
dixmud lors de cette 4e édition le
record est déjà battu plus de 2000
livres CD et DVD ont été échangés entre
les TR cœur ce weekend à plaisir ici à
leur arrivée les organisateurs mettent
des points à chaque article amené par
les participants en fonction de leur
valeur avec leurs points les trokers
peuvent ensuite se servir j'ai amené
beaucoup de DVD et de CD j'ai eu
beaucoup de points donc j'en ai profité
pour me faire une vraie bibliothèque
jeunesse donc qui va m'être très utile
la bibliothèque est encombrée donc bah
envie de renouveler envie que ça profite
à quelqu'un donc voilà c'est aussi un
lieu de rencontre et puis puis euh ça
permet de se donner des
idées savoir qui a aimé quoi et de
partager des lecture aussi hein voilà
puis ça évite d'acheter et on peut
mettre le budget d'une autre
manière à l'origine de cet événement
l'association des résidents des Gâtines
et du plateau de plaisir en 4 ans pour
élargir leur public plusieurs concepts
ont été créés comme ce coin enfant ou
encore ces articles spécial coup de cœur
la nouveauté cette année c'est l'espace
gratuit le but ici c'est c'est un
au-delà du troc c'est c'est surtout
faire plaisir aux gens qui viennent et
c'est faire en sorte qu'ils repartent
avec des livre donc on a fait un petit
coin un petit peu entre guillemets
gratuit où là il y a pas besoin il y a
pas besoin d'échange une partie des
stocks restants est ensuite reversé à
des associations
plaisiroises voilà pour terminer cette
édition l'appel lancé par le club de
football de guilloncour Émile leuga vous
allez voir sa photo dirigeant du club a
disparu depuis mardi 11h depuis lundi
pardon 11h à Guillon en cours cet homme
de 80 ans est vêtu d'une polaire noire
avec une écharpe bleue ciel et un
pantalon noir également il porte des
lunettes vous voyez sa photo et si vous
l'avez vu vous pouvez communiquer ces
des informations auprès de la police
nationale voilà cette cette h lactu est
terminé merci de votre attention je vous
souhaite une excellente
[Musique]
soirée